attendez coupé et ce sera pareil vous
deviez vous tenir là pour la lumière mon
dieu fait sortir cet idiot
[Musique]
je ne veux plus jamais vous voir ne vous
avisez pas de remettre un pied sur cette
propriété
le prix si c'est quoi ton milieu et
milan
demain c'est le dernier jour de tournage
ensuite on rentre à paris
berlin est en plein état d'urgence ils
ont fermé la frontière est ouest
je dois vraiment évident que les
n'approchez pas ou je tire
elle doit déjà être dans un avion elle
est partie
j'ai trouvé le moyen de rêver de revoir
mulhouse sans tarder tu veux faire un
film
ouais c'est vraiment la chose la plus
folle la plus idiote et la plus belle
que j'ai jamais vu et quel genre de film
ce serait un tout petit film ce sera
facile un projet de prestige du
socialisme je ferais mieux d'aller
écrire mon scénario je crois tu veux
tout mettre en jeu pour revoir une fille
alors que tu ne sais même pas s'il veut
te revoir
[Musique]
la dernière fois que je t'ai vu tu
n'étais qu'un petit figurants et
maintenant voilà réalisateur j'ignorais
qu entre vous deux
tu sais que tu risque d'aller en prison
si jamais quelqu'un découvre la
supercherie
tu n'as rien à lui offrir le vérifier
vous savez ce qui vous reste à faire
oui
[Musique]
ne retourne pas à paris je ne peux pas
rester ici
ce papa